foreign
Oxford in March 2022 in which a Dr Dame
June rain who is speaking on behalf of
the regulatory agency in Great Britain
known as the mhra that's the medical and
health care products regulatory agency
the tagline for which is regulating
medicines and medical devices so it's
basically if you're American that sounds
like the FDA the analog to the FDA she
gives a talk about the mhra about the
medical and Healthcare products
regulatory agency
which remarkably she calls from Watchdog
to enabler
regulation in covet and after so I've
got five screenshots from the talk
um
so uh and again I'll link to the talk in
the show notes as well associated with
this screenshot with her introducing her
talk here she says
I'm going to talk about how the code
quote how the covet pandemic has
catalyzed the transformation of a
regulator from a watchdog to an enabler
and I was telling you about this Brett
you were like enabler of what like of
Pfizer of the pharmaceutical companies
she's mostly talking about the Pfizer
shots in this talk but she also goes
into tying my AstraZeneca a little bit
but almost entirely she is talking about
being proud to have moved a regulatory
agency from being have understanding its
role as that of watchdog
to that of being an enabler of the
developers of the treatments that are
being brought to them in this case the
Pfizer bioin Tech vaccine it's a classic
case of saying the quiet part out loud
it's a jaw-dropping I recommend this
it's you know it's 25 minutes or so and
you can skim parts of it it's you know
sort of standard academic conferencing
stuff
um the next and just a few screenshots
here next screenshot Zach uh here we
have on the screen a couple of little
speech bubbles and
what she says associated with this is so
I was dashing into number 10 for a
meeting in the cabinet office
right so she's you know she's important
enough to be that's number 10 Downing
Street of course um that's like saying
so I was dashing into the White House
for meeting at the cabinet office if she
was American and in that meeting in that
meeting at number 10 in the cabinet
office she is asked as it shows on
screen
by someone I didn't catch the name uh
will the mhra stop us from killing
people
and she immediately responded no the HRA
will help you keep people alive
and this is how she understands her role
changing as a regulator as a person
who's helping lead a regulatory agency
through an emergency is no I'm not going
to put the brakes on I'm gonna speed
things up
so again proud enough of this to have it
on screen okay next screenshot
uh this is just this is not all that
informative this has the tagline for
mhra but what accompanies are saying
this uh what a company what accompanies
her showing these agencies that are
collaborating now under under her
watchful guidance is quote we
collaborated across these boundaries as
never before and she does say she knows
we need to remain independent that's
really important but then she says
enthusiastically that quote we tore up
the rule book
but during covet we the regulatory
agency in of Great Britain tore up the
rule book
okay next screenshot
so this
shows uh the mhra having facilitated
having allowed Pharma Pharma to change
the timing of clinical trials whereas
used to be phase one phase two phase
three had phase one had to actually be
done before he went into phase two and
phase two had to be done before you went
to phase three
um she she is proud of the fact that
during covet under mhra they changed the
guidelines so that now pharmaceutical
companies could modify the timing of the
clinical trial such that you could have
the phases overlapping one another and
she says quote of the vaccines
which had begun to be manufactured well
before even the first phase was done
first phase of the clinical trial was
done quote large-scale manufacture was
prepared at risk we did not know if any
of these vaccines would be effective end
quote but surely surely everyone even
this audience that this small audience
where she's giving this talk at Oxford
in March of 2022 can see that at the
point that the government has purchased
in advance the large-scale manufacturer
of a whole bunch of vaccines and they
don't actually have the safety data yet
but it's going to be that much harder
to say actually no all of those have to
go into the trash
I hate to say it but it's worse than
that it is because if you if you listen
to this knowing what has taken place
during this process right if you know
what we know now about what took place
in the drug trials for example
there was never any risk that these
vaccines were not going to be safe and
effective right
in which case why not do this right like
why not just overlap phase one phase two
that's just the thing this is pro forma
the idea is what we now have is a safety
system incapable of recognizing a safety
signal that is really just a a
laundering a safety and Effectiveness
laundering apparatus for that is
um effectively a branch of Pharma and if
that sounds hyperbolic no I know in the
U.S that a tremendous percentage of the
money that flows through the regulatory
apparatus is actually Pharma money right
that the system has been built to fail
where the controls have been handed to
Pharma the financial controls the power
of the purse effectively and
what
what this sounds like to me
if you were if you've got if you're
Pharma then you ought to live in fear
that the regulatory apparatus is going
to be uh uncompelled that your product
is safe and or effective that's what
they're there for and really if you're
Pharma you ought not live in fear
because you ought to know the regulatory
apparatus is there and therefore you
ought to do your damn job and produce a
safe and effective product to begin with
right but of course uh the fiduciary
responsibility of the corporation is uh
clear and the fact is it was very
expedient from the point of view of
taking care of their shareholders to
capture the apparatus so there was never
any risk right that at a business level
that makes sense it's criminal but
um at a business level it makes sense
and so if you were to do that if there
is a governmental regulatory apparatus
its purpose is to prevent dangerous and
or ineffective treatments from making it
to Market Pharma can't tolerate that
because
business is difficult so it captures
that apparatus it's still the zombies
inside of that apparatus still exist
they still have to give speeches about
their role in the process and they have
to occasionally wag their finger at
Pharma in order that they still look
like a regulatory apparatus but
basically what will they sound like to
themselves right they will sound like
they think it is clever that they tore
up the rule book right they will be
proud of the fact that their Watchdog
role has been transformed into enabler
which surely is not the term she was
looking for facilitator it was literally
in the title of the talk right so the
point is
to the extent that people talk behind
closed doors and they say things that
they wouldn't and shouldn't in public
this is one of these cases where enabler
sounds like internal language it sounds
like frankly Pharma language right where
actually we're gonna get the regulatory
apparatus to function as an enabler of
this process well maybe she's the
Rochelle wolinsky of that is exactly
what I'm getting is let's put it this
way
what Pharma did is Despicable but it
makes sense right what these people do
is Despicable but it makes sense right
these are careers that are being made
how is your career being made is it
being made by being a good Watchdog no
that'll get you tossed out on your ear
right it's being made by transitioning
Your Role from Watchdog to enabler right
that's how you rise and so the point is
we are hearing
this weird mixture of the internal
dialogue and the Public Presentation of
you know the Victory lap and it's like
well hey what are you taking a Victory
lap about it's not like you distributed
a product that worked right it didn't
and what's more it was hugely dangerous
so
why you know why are you championing the
change in the process that you you
shepherded but
nonetheless we get to hear it and it
does sound like
um
it sounds like what you would imagine a
captured regulatory industry uh
apparatus is like on the inside yeah
right as it rationalizes to itself it's
failure totally and actually the last
screenshot which isn't uh isn't a giant
deal but uh I'm gonna show it Zack
uh proudly discusses the agency's
regulatory flexibilities
and you know that that like enabler
strikes me as a word that they really
had and not publicized they they are as
you say saying the quiet part out loud
here and yet and you know as easy as
they're making it for those of us who
are paying attention
still
still we are the ones who are considered
to be purveyors of Miss dis smell and
all the other bad types of information
yes which of course have been declared
terrorism
yes I don't know if they have them Great
Britain or not but well I mean Great
Britain is one of the five eyes no doubt
terrorism here is Terrorism there that's
probably true so yeah yeah
so that um that happened back in March
2022
um and uh
it's shocking frankly I I I'm no less
shocked than if
than if the FDA I don't even know who
the lead on the FDA is but some
equivalent person at the FDA to
to this woman at the at the fda's analog
in in Great Britain
had had saved these things we are
proudly moving we're excited we're
excited to have thrown away the rule
book
to have moved from Watchdog capacity to
enabler
to be engaging in regulatory
flexibilities
and and anyone is confused as to the
lack of oversight
and the fact that we don't actually lots
and lots of people ever more every day
are saying I don't actually trust you
guys to make decisions on my behalf now
no not you not now
yeah well the um
one of the truly evil aspects of this is
that many of us were calling attention
to the evidence of what was going on as
it happened and the evidence was of
course less than it is now right but
that was a very risky thing to do right
and
um we can now see
that you know
what should be a
alarm Bell going off at the
acknowledgment that in fact there are
reproductive consequences to these
products
um and that that ought to cause a
rethink probably temporary probably
temporary right but the point is you
what you can see for sure now with the
amount of evidence that is currently
available even just to the General
Public
what you can see is that the system is
completely indifferent to the risk it's
putting citizens to have completely
indifferent it is not changing its tune
about whether or not you should be
inoculated with this stuff based on the
alarming evidence of the safety signal
based on the evidence of the
ineffectiveness of the shots at
preventing you from Contracting or
transmitting the disease it has yet to
do any attempt at risk stratification
analysis no evidence of risk
stratification which tells you right
there that this process has nothing to
do with health because the cost benefit
analysis is obviously risk stratified
which is just to say again like Risk
stratification by age and this is
something we've talked about before in
many many doctors have as well we have
known from the beginning
that this virus is much more likely to
bring you to your knees the older you
are also the more comorbidities but the
risk stratification by age means that
given that the virus is very unlikely to
do you harm if you are a healthy young
person and also separately the vaccines
seem to be more likely to do you harm
the younger you are wrist stratification
analysis would suggest that there should
be different guidelines for at the very
least different guidelines for whether
or not you're expected to take this
thing steeply different steeply
different and yet what most the elite
universities in the United States are
now requiring not just vaccines but
boosters for their students for their
presumably young healthy student
populations are you trying to kill them
what is going on right it's insane you
should have let's put it this way the
date if there is an argument for these
so-called vaccines at all
there should be an age at which the cost
benefit analysis flips enough in their
favor that we recommend it and that age
should be in motion with more evidence
that we have and the fact that that age
doesn't exist at all we're just like oh
they're good get them yeah right that's
like well six months old get them
pregnant get it right yeah that's that
is a
manufacturer's view of a product is this
product for you definitely yes right
there is no it's not a question well who
are you let's figure out whether this
product is for you you can see that and
so as well you're human we got a thing
for you as long as you can see that that
is what's going on that the thing is not
interested in who you are even though
the evidence suggests that that should
be the primary question in deciding
whether or not to recommend it and that
it isn't just the manufacturers who are
so indifferent to your well-being it's
the thing that is supposed to be
protecting you once you've seen that
then the real question is well was that
true from the start what about all that
[ __ ] you told me that turned out it
wasn't right did you know it wasn't
right right right that's really the
question and
um I do hope we ultimately I I doubt we
will ever get a full Reckoning but we
have to we have to try because
um to the extent that the system
that allowed this to happen is
completely captured and we are dependent
on its functioning not just this time
but next time
it won't be better next time unless we
figure out
what got into it that's right no and one
of one of the
um recurring themes in that video that I
showed you screenshots of from Oxford in
March of 2022
is the is the rejoicing that during the
next pandemic and there will be a next
one she proclaims and it's true
they've already got all these changes in
place so it'll be easier next time it'll
be easier next time to be the enabler
and no worries about them being a
watchdog
[Music]